In September, global business and political leaders will gather in Dalian, the northeastern city of China, to explore the economic recovery.
Although the government’s economic stimulus plan can be urgently needed in the short term,
The driving force behind the long-term “transformation” recovery of the global economy will come from entrepreneurship, innovation and technological advancement.
The main force leading this economic recovery will be a new generation of leaders - the new leader,
They will gather in the "Summer Davos" under the auspices of the World Economic Road Forum.
However, the key issues are:
“Can China lead us out of the economic crisis?”
Can China be an important driving force to help the world economy emerge from the current recession?
What's your opinion?
You only need to vote in our survey,
And upload your speech video to the network!
Your video will be shown at the annual meeting of the New Champions in Dalian.
We will call on the leaders to focus on responding to your video.
Thank you!